oh my gosh we're back again and it feels
so good a jock storm is in the building
everyone at Dan Tana's can I get some
noise please go date - Sam telling you
how good how are you how are you
you almost did it right there you almost
did this I almost did it but I just in
all of your IG pictures it's yeah what
is that where does that come from
Carolina like one of my love gnarly
things that I do rocked in this yeah
just like it's just me you're asking
about the status of our podcast yeah
that's what we got it's gonna be here
tomorrow
deejay lots of but in the flesh can we
can we talk about one other thing with
him real quick just like his cane I mean
he King Tut over here oh look at King
Tut first of all see this is my thing I
like it he's got the cane and then the
rest state is like I said you know
before we've been here before yeah I'm
sure like you know what I'm saying in I
think is for me back in the day Kings
and P white they were had scepters right
yeah carry those things yeah and they
see these stuff and it's like they
associate it with pimping yeah it's like
the new generation before it was
something else and then now it's like if
Jesus a half-gainer walk you got to be
hurt yeah well you gotta be Oh like come
on man I just can't have this so my
short version like this this is my
cigarettes and I'm gonna like it so wet
I love it did you like I know you went
to Israel last year is this from there
yes the monkey like hear no evil see no
evil right speak no evil it is and it's
a great comment like carry it and no
well I'll tell you the story yes we
ought to hear it I was in Orlando right
and I was going through Disney World
theme park and I was my daughter and my
brother
and everybody and their kids and we was
walking and I got tired so I was like
huh let me just have something to walk
with and was walking through the African
safari and it was kind of crazy because
it monkeys and everything to go wild and
then my African brother he was on the
side carving this you know the stick
yeah I was looking at it I was just
appreciating his you know artistry his
craft very much so I call it artistry
because this is like a world is you
can't meet this with anything so I saw
it and I looked at it and I was like man
I do need a stick so I had to choose
between two and my little daughter she
was right there with me and then she
ended up you know choosing this which
one I was gonna walk with and she picked
this one and so I looked at it and the
guy who carved it for me he was like you
know this is see no evil speak no evil
hear no evil so the only minutes you put
whenever you go into someone house you
give him that gift and it Ward's off the
bad spirits and I was like wow that's
pretty cool
so I had an eye for a little bit I was
like and I stuck with me I love to
position like jackass and I'm curious
like Dancing with the Stars all that
stuff I went through your IG and like
the earlier photos like you were putting
up pictures of cake like you're like oh
it's like a normal Instagram post but
now it's like all this stuff what's it
like being known in the NFL because I
always hear NFL players talk about their
not knowing the helmets on people know
you what is that like eight evolve you
know it always work of I mean it's a
time for sure but I always maintain
myself in who I was I don't think I've
ever wavered from that and it just took
a time people just got used to that and
got hooked and and see how we do it but
it's just you know I don't know God's
good so grace has been with me
throughout the time and somehow one play
here when played there and next thing
you know we took off and then went on to
something else and that was greater than
the next thing and so before you know it
you know
here - enjoyment is always it comes in
with a song jay-z and the lyrics and
it's just I don't know jay-z's are exact
crazy but I will I will say what he said
he's been the same guy I knew him before
he was Josh Norman shut down corner
because I was training up there in
Jersey and I played Murray from Reese's
and he was the same guy but you know of
course now we know his face he's got a
little cash in his pocket and he's up
this game start with this guy left go um
I want to start so I went and hung out
with Josh like two three years ago now
and we were going house shopping and
apparently you have a house yes do you
have horses at this house
no not yet okay I was gonna say Delta to
call those guys yeah see Delta thing is
he's on pop farm back in Greenwood so
he's cut wrong yeah I like Josh over
this country this is this is not a city
slicker for DC not at all not at all I
come from there with five brothers and
we just all out there in the country
just going crazy with each other all
those horses so what else can you do for
fight each other and ride horses are you
still listening to the Batman theme song
before games yeah still get into those
explained players are always crazy but
like we got a Brian Dawkins Jersey in
the front row
he became Weapon X on game day and
you've seen that in the Batman nation
yeah I tried to play the theme song with
Josh Norman in the car and he shut it
off he goes don't do that you don't want
to see me when I listen to that song
what how does it how does it kind of
like what does it do to you man well it
takes me to a certain place in time I
think when everybody listen to a song or
you know they hear something you always
equate that with a certain place in time
where you were when you heard that song
or whatever that case may be me you know
hearing that music from that soundtrack
you know puts me in the place of that
movie
from while I was watching it and like
what it means okay okay what's the movie
or the place yeah like I'd like to hear
that part of it
oh no that's the part where it rises you
know he gets into the Batmobile he speed
us off and he's going you know fight um
bang yeah baby that was that was the
part where I'm kind of like that's where
you envision when you look across you
see Odell wearing a joker mask like are
you like this is perfect
oh yeah Leila they're sure right yeah
just give it to it by night yeah let's
get into it
like how's that relationship going
what's it been like two times a year
ever since that epoch God just
dysfunctional thing you guys went
through he's my guy he's cool though
yeah he's cool he's alright yeah I think
the thing gives with him and it was just
everything took place in a time in which
it was then and then the media just took
it onto and hold it really well yeah I
just just put stuff on top of it that
wasn't even there you know it was plain
each other it was just like dude I have
no animosity go holy crap we've never
seen anything like that in the history
in the league like just two guys that
I'm not trying to be a jerk just go at
it and I know who you are like football
lovers I'm original and it just and you
were the 15 in one Carolina Panthers
that he was the big bad storm it was a
lot of that you know and then coming in
Gotham City as they say New York is a
dark night and then you give him the
character the Joker and he plays that
role in the villain just to the teeth
then we go out there and square off like
yeah it was fireworks so go back I say
I'm not looking at now but years years
on down the road
you know guys take it to the you know
that step so the cannon if that happens
I don't know whatever we working towards
right right so it's like we get to that
point we could look back over at all and
just be like you know what did your son
say about Josh Norman the other day I
told my son so last night I'm on the
phone with them they didn't have school
so it's about 10:45 and we let them stay
up my kids late when they don't have
school
the next day right they can stay up play
video games he's playing fortnight I'm
sure something like that but he gets on
the phone and hate dad hey what you're
doing you know and then though I'm good
no who'd you talk to today and I told my
talk to deshaun Watson yes oh that's an
accent no an to Sean Jackson Sean Watson
- and then so he goes alright so we
gonna talk to you tomorrow
and I was like Josh Norman he goes Oh
Josh Norman I mean dad he might be the
greatest corner in the history that I
got some ways to go I got ways to go
night impression on a young generation
just so you know that well yeah that
you're a baller well I appreciate that
um a lot don't wait I have fun with it I
really do and you know I go out there
and I try to win its best as I can for
the team and everybody that's around us
you just to make us better in whatever I
can do I try to be a servant of it
instant game did you see the injury
happened to Alex Oriakhi sideline I was
in a sideline so we'll sit down was
probably getting talk to you about when
our coaches in you know everybody was
like ooh or something I saw him down but
I'm like okay he's just gonna probably
pop back up and you think nothing of it
but say he's broken his old leg in half
and it was just like oh it was bad
because I didn't see it and but I just
walked out there because I knew he
couldn't move his leg and I was like
something really has happened right he's
rolled something but I know it was that
severe yeah I saw a picture of him in
the Washington Capitals locker room and
I've never seen a leg with that many
thing and it's like he's not going to
play at all next year he's out he's out
he's out I gotta go talk to him when we
get back to but it's just yeah I mean I
pray for that because it's a situation
where it could be like career-ending
yeah which is like for a guy like Alex
who has fought so long and hard in this
NFL to get the respect and to get the
time and then have a team that goes
you're the guy and then I'm hoping it's
it's not me - and that's what you gotta
pray for you know the best because for a
guy like that you know to come into a
team like we have it up in DC
you know a guy that's already known for
his wins like he does not lose you gang
right he will put you in them and he
will win him he did not lose you games
and that's the thing you know we were
six and three six three whatever at that
part when he went down and after that
you saw how you know how season started
the hit the other way right and it feels
in the game I guarantee you at least two
of those would have been ours well let's
let's start there
the state of your team like just got out
overall I mean there's been a lot of
stuff especially on the defensive side
of the ball and DJ swear injure yeah who
looked like he was trying to be the
leader of the team but he's spouting off
about the coach he's talking about Jay
Gruden's not a born winner all that I
mean what are you gonna say to like all
that crap because I stand with DJ job
just saying this right now I stay I do I
I think that and this is like reading
his thing he's like I'm at practice
trying to get these guys going why is
that an issue I don't know is that crazy
I don't think it's a little crazy yes I
do
I'll say that well I mean it's alright
don't worry I mean no I you know you
have superiors and in a day exactly
right and you we're still working and we
can't take that out of context you know
I like chaos man I'm like the joke see I
know you're Batman yeah he was on your
team because he's a Eagles fan
no it's just the fact that we understand
it we play you know a kids game for
king's ransom and in regardless out of
fact we still have to be you know
respect to the superiorities and
regardless of the fact whether you know
I condone it or not you know it's
something that happened he's no longer
with the team so you can't really you
know say what you feel on the issue
because he's not with us right so if I
was to say something you know that's
derogatory or something towards him I
wouldn't do it because that'd be a
disrespectful other situation and I just
feel like you know that had its moment
in time and that's just what happened
yeah is there a part of you guys though
like as an Eagles fan there was always
the question heading into the season
when is Carson gonna be back and it was
like this looming cloud of doubt
because you know that Alex is definitely
not coming back this season yeah
is there a part of the team that's like
all right it's time to move forward yes
there is moving on they're gonna the
quarterback I I don't know I think yeah
maybe personal against Alec it's nice
nothing gives me knows that yeah
understands that trust me he's far well
sit for us is like regardless of the
fact where he's plays at night but he
wants to play the game and if he still
can shoot why not get back out there and
show what he can do but for the state of
the franchise in itself I feel like you
we have you have to I mean you really
have to because you know in this league
right now just important point in time
if you have no quarterback you're not
winning right and it going to show you
that we can a week out by what is being
called against on the defense
let's defense more score right and it's
been preached that for the last five
years of something that's so now is
starting to take this whole entire mark
to where now we get to this point where
you starting to see the games where
you're getting 40 points in people
average and 20-plus did I never had like
it's crazy because you can't catch
anybody I know anything and if you do
you get set up for it in the game to
give them a big plates where they moving
to score and drive and then they they
didn't get it through a ball of the
double coverage you know that's what I'm
saying so it's like it's him it's kind
of like embarrassing to play defense now
because of that like how can you
you got to play against the quarterback
and the opposing team which we know who
they are so it's tough it really is
tough to play that position and be
coached in that because you can't hit
nobody anymore can't take them to the
ground unless you're Seifert around
I mean you play playoff football you
went to a Super Bowl why I mean you knew
that when the playoffs started the refs
we're gonna become chicken [ __ ] with the
flags I mean for sure I read the
difference the thing is they really do
and I hate using the game to know like
you know it's the pie
that's right or let's play yeah I know
let's play and I know they're gonna let
us play and I you gotta go and check the
referees before though you gotta test it
you gotta have a conversation with it
and see where they had today you know
you can see that by just having
conversation and I do it every time I
check with them right away because I
know what kind of day is gonna be for me
yes do to solve a big podcast thing for
us that we've had for a long time mm-hmm
you are a big-time world football fan I
think you love psg police ain't your man
I've seen you go to their facilities I
see you take pictures with Pogba all
this stuff Sims believes yeah that if
our best athletes the Odell's of the
world you you Leo and Tony are on yeah
from the time they were born played
soccer we would steamroll the
round-the-world nation that's his belief
it's a needler pond enjoy so you're you
know both sports so I'm looking for your
insight here your assessment I'm not I'm
not trying to like trash them right but
so do I really have answers but I mean
it's like a no-brainer though so it's
like a no-brainer it's a no-brainer yeah
yes of course it is
yes like well like that's not even
enough for a debate or discussion though
girl soccer fans always come back and
say it's not about strength or speed
it's about touch and feel if the field
in the world came because he was out
there the nobody else that's the case
that's the case me and Papa have an
online challenge if you feel that way
pull up a challenge and see where me and
him was going at each other and go and
see who won that challenge okay I guess
a world-class marksman like Slaton elite
level athletes sure yeah we're never
make it in the NFL I just you know I
picked the difference because I feel
like it's my said but he's so big
I feel like if he was training towards
that level [ __ ] he could play in the NFL
I kill race it's not like it's not a
question he'll being bopping you know
what I'm saying on a wing or something
so you got a tire big hill for sure
you're gonna send him up the wing and
you're gonna give him pass the ball yeah
you know tor Odell he hit the ball yeah
do it like a finesse shot or something
and and that's the thing that people
don't realize and understand you have
all these players they wouldn't be so
much talking about Cristiano Ronaldo or
Messi I was on two people you probably
hear but we have those guys and our
stable you can only just take you take
just NFL force instance yeah but you got
NBA is weight right and you have
baseball major league baseball yeah come
on you also went on a team like man all
right man we'll hire them well us
haven't you your grave can we get a
round of applause for Josh please my man
my man so Josh yes I'm gonna hit you up
later
let me know what makes imagine he's
trying to achieve Josh if you want to
sit here while we do the news you can if
not yeah I got news yeah just today no
just stuff that talked about today but
whatever you want to do so I don't know
if you guys saw this say Quan came out
and said I believe I should be Rookie of
the Year over Baker Mayfield and I'm
curious we said I said earlier this
season it should go to say Quan I
believe you said sake one I don't even
know if this is news he's the rookie of
the whole year we didn't even ask you
about it I didn't get to ask you about
players I mean damn damn
but yes speak about say Kwan and his
quads and his beautiful body I agree
with ya do tell yeah why not
I mean you see what he do what he did
right can you explain it though because
this is a fantasy world where we look at
statistics and points from a football
player perspective why is sake walnut
Rookie of the Year I mean the guy I got
shoot I mean he has a little bit of Eric
Dickerson when he can get something open
he got speed he has definitely Barry
Sanders elusiveness and breaking tackles
oh my gosh I mean go Walter Payton he
has us a little bit of that until them
too cause he is ferocious and takes on
the tackle got a little bit my all-star
believe it or not yeah I'm taking
running people over yeah I witnessed one
of those plays I came down the hill that
thing opened up like the Red Sea and it
was just me and him and I'm telling I
was trying to take his head off as soon
as I came through that whole ice met
them there I met him at the line I'm
talking about I stopped my feet here's a
steel chairs like okay yeah all right I
know for next time so oh no but he's
he's definitely amazing talent anyway
he's hurtles I to its I feel like that I
seen him a couple of times it's almost a
no-brainer to me awesome get out of here
dad to telling us you got to go
appreciate you man you are the man Josh
Josh Norman aka King Tut so the the only
other guy that would be up I think for
Offensive Rookie of the Year would be
our home he quit Nelson was here
yesterday right appreciate you I just
want to say one more thing about sake
one two yes because you say Kwan I do
think in this especially a Baker
Mayfield you guys all agree right Baker
was awesome this year right he has
changed the culture but I always put it
like this the sake one first of all we
talked all year about how crappy the
Giants outline was right here offending
Eli and defending Eli how crappy it is
it wasn't great but then you got say
Kwan who averaged five yards per carry
and had over 2000 total yards his third
and rushing in the NFL I don't to me
that's the thing I evaluate right like
who's there to help you and I don't
think he had a ton of help and we
you can make people miss and break
tackles and make people like Josh Norman
go like whoa
yeah that's when you know you're next
level so we had the homie quit Nelson on
yesterday and I got a chance to get
lunch with him today and I just want to
say that I made him eat chicken and
waffles for the first time in his life
thank you
do your IQ do your impersonation and
everything clean don't be a down well no
because he was just like he was like how
do you eat this and this is my trick for
everybody it's waffle syrup then chicken
so you don't soggy up the chicken then
hot sauce and I'm explaining it to him
by the Thai sauce yes on waffles and
chip once listen bro damn I cannot if
you're not school to the game I got you
but as I'm explaining it to him he
already took the other waffle and put it
on top and he was like I like sandwiches
I was like you do it but you do it but
he was awesome all right so I love that
he said that about c'est quoi yeah I
love when NFL athletes can admit that
another guy right is crazy right cuz
it's you know it's not an ego thing he's
just really that good he appreciates it
just like we do his fans and then we
always say that players are fans too we
can also appreciate for us other
broadcasters Yeah right and the one
that's getting a lot of attention right
now is tony romo ski Tony Romo the guy
that shares the exact same body type as
myself but I think what's really funny
is is like this entire Super Bowl I feel
like it's about Tony Romo like there's a
Vegas prop of seven and a half correct
guesses right for Tony Romo in the game
pound the under you're going over no
because I we know how TV works and we
know that the producers it like in the
pre-production meeting going we don't
want to take away from the game let's
not do it too much but I also think that
in the Super Bowl that's when crazy
plays happen agree and they try to make
it look one way and do the other I think
we're gonna get a lot of Tony Romo
incorrect guesses in this case well you
could you're putting the Voodoo on them
right now
but but no I think to that is a good
point it's the Super Bowl teams do
change up tendencies so whereas a
quarterback or somebody that follows the
game like Tony does the studies that I
think some of those plays that he
studied New England do all year where he
was on point writing AFC championship
gave all of he motions over they're
gonna run over here yeah they're this
they're all have a few tricks up their
sleeves both sides where it'll even
throw Tony Romo off a little bit I would
suggest to him not guess too much early
yeah right and then he'll get to see the
game flow you'll get a feel for some of
the things they're trying to do
differently and then he'll be on point
but it's amazing what he does he loves
football and I appreciate that I do
choose there are broadcasters out there
that I sometimes watch and I go I don't
know if you've watched any of these
games yeah right like the lower level
like all right it's Cincinnati Cleveland
and it's like alright thanks man way to
show up you knew the two teams that was
great yeah yeah has your mind changed at
all about the game I always want to do
the Sims check it because sometimes you
think of new things no no I'm not
changing you know the only I'm picking
the Patriots to win like 27 23 somewhere
right in that range I'm going with that
now I I do am I scared a little of
course it's the damn Super Bowl they're
both really good and I'm taking the team
that's less talented like the Rams are
the more talented team and that's no
disrespect to the Patriots right but
that Rams got like we've said all-stars
freaks of nature who can make plays that
Bill Belichick and Brady might not be
able to overcome and certain instances
and that always scares me to a degree
yeah
so Brian Hoyer was asked about Tom
Brady's retirement which is another
storyline that people even though he's
definitely not retiring we love to talk
about it his comment was I think people
maybe just want to him to retire because
they're sick of seeing him do well yeah
I think we get tired of certain
narratives but I kind of want to ask you
what is a realistic year that Brady
might retire factoring in Josh McDaniels
is locked in right if Bella cheque
leaves right and crock is probably gonna
retire after this year so he loses one
of his buddies yep but his play and the
health around him what year do you put
on Brady I'm gonna say 2020 that's gonna
be his last year
very like that feels soon to me no I was
thinking like 20 22 that's two years I
mean and and one year is at this age at
forty forty-one it's like in football
lives every year is like five years I
mean that that's you're gonna see I
didn't see him get hit all year yeah but
we had we had points during the year
where all people did was he doesn't look
the same and he went through some rough
spots where he wasn't maybe as magical
as years passed right 20 20 20 20
because the end of Braden he's still
gonna be able to throw it like that's
not gonna go away what he's done and
adjusting his mechanics and you guys saw
some of the throws he made last week and
in the end the AFC divisional game that
we throw against Miami the beautiful
cordarrelle Patterson yeah I mean that's
those are big-time like some of the best
arms and football can only make those
throws but I do think yes if he the way
they play is going to see them two years
is a lot it's a lot in football and I do
think the way they're gonna play will
keep him upright you guys see how much
they're running the ball now right
play-action pass you if you've listened
to me like the last few podcasts I
always say like Justin Houston D Ford
Ingram both so they don't even know what
color Brady's eyes are they didn't even
get close enough to go like oh look at
those beautiful eyes he's so handsome
like not even close annoy with the
breath right there you go right like you
don't even know what his breath smells
like that's how phenomenal he isn't
getting the bottom his hand right but
the stress they put you under with their
game plan it protects you know him and
not having to get hand the ball hand
them all I got to worry about the run I
got worried about the run oh wait he
kept the ball I gotta try to get rush
after him now and he's amazing at doing
that you see what I just looked up Oh
would you look up I looked up when
gizelle and Tom Brady got married
because I see some grown men in the
audience and you know that if your wife
says you got a stop
that might stop you more than your
abilities we got to be honest here
they've been married for 10 years yeah
this February right I'm one one thing
wives have no jurisdiction over I'm
sorry
I don't know how your wife makes my
money why he makes more money than that
vet would write that even proves it even
more he's extra psycho he doesn't even
care he's like I'm playing football
honey I don't care you know what you
signed up for when we got married I
don't know and that's where I believe
there is a secret gizelle Brady PAC
that they've agreed on a date and at
that moment it is over and she goes into
spine you play until February 2020
cuz you might be right right and then
after that get back at home I know that
your man you think was that much German
all of my accents go sideways yes keep
coming oh we talked about this the other
day this wasn't on the podcast I was
saying that it kind of looks like Matt
Stafford's arm I'm a little bit worried
that it's gonna get less and you said
guys like Stafford and Rogers their arms
never get less strong now so who are the
guys like that and why is that the case
well they're just third natural gifted
throwers that's like mahomes will have
this arm until he's fitting to say it's
like gonna be as strong right like Brady
Brady can throw it forever like it might
not be as strong as it was like say ten
years ago in 2007 or like that but it's
not far off where he's always gonna be
able to make all the throws even when
he's like 55 he's gonna be like damn I
could still throw it if they just
wouldn't that my dad always says if they
wouldn't hit me I could still play horse
but they're fill the Hall of Fame there
are naturals though there who are the
quarterbacks that actually fall off the
guys that actually like I worry about
Philip Rivers Philip Rivers you saw at
the end of the year right even in the
New England it like everything he had to
throw it 40 yards down the field Drew
Brees is another one I worry the Saints
finally a jerk Drew's a man we know that
and you guys got screwed sorry all right
screwed but I look at a guy like that
and go yes it will it will fall off a
Narine as the year went on this year
drew they weren't able to stretch the
field out as much that would be one guy
I would look at trying to look like
deshaun Watson it'll never fall off what
about Andrew Luck Andrew Luck it will
fall off if he doesn't make adjustments
it's too mechanical and you guys see the
way Andrew Luck throws right it's it's
so deliberate and over the top and he's
really strong and he can get away with
it but I don't know if that's going to
last the test of time that's like what
happened to Peyton Manning right Peyton
was the man all-time legend one of the
greatest ever but at the end come on
that thing was a wet noodle I mean it
was a wet noodle
17 interceptions
and his motion was so high and it went
just like this right I mean it was like
from here to here watch how it basically
went from up here to the opposite pocket
yeah and you won't see Brady throw like
that on Sunday at the Super Bowl it's
more across right if you want to throw a
ball hard that way your arms got to go
that way at some point to apply the
force there yeah and so I look at that
Big Bend we're seeing he's not gonna
fall off natural throw it just doesn't
matter what the object is if they've
decided they wanted to play baseball and
be pitcher some of these guys were
talking about yeah they'd be major
league starters and be you know top of
the line kind of guys other quarterback
in this matchup Jared Goff yeah
apparently Andrew Whitworth son comes on
stage and golf promises him to buy him a
shark what if the Rams win the Superbowl
Ark I don't know but as an
environmentally friendly person are you
are you upset about this well I'm not
like I'm never a fan of like putting any
barium like that's just not cool I mean
I don't know I mean maybe if Whitworth
rich enough to buy a giant aquarium so
if he wants to do that but I mean I'm
you know I don't love that yeah I've
never loved share with them the animals
that you own well I own three cats and a
dog at this point our chickens and ducks
got eaten this summer yes all right it's
very tough yeah you know it's hard
living out there and the but my little
girl came down and ate his channel hawk
coyote my little girl she loves animals
she wants to be a farmer that's all she
wants to do in life
so she's literally I'm working here to
buy her a farm that's the only reason he
is Matt Damon that movie we bought us
you're exactly right like that's who he
is in real life and she gets up in the
morning and she's like total put the
overalls on and she got her bucket she'd
let the chickens out and make sure
things were you know everything was
clean and feed them and they would
free-range but in the summertime I mean
the animals come out and we watch to
kayo I her life one of her first life
lessons Martin Luther King Day two years
ago I walk out in the back patio not to
do daddy cigars it was early in the
morning right but I walk out in the back
patio and I look down I could see one of
her chickens is being eaten by a hawk
right there and I kind of went
she was in the in the family room and
she saw my rack she's like what what
how's it gone don't look it's not a big
deal whatever I tried it no no I want to
see and she saw it she handled it like a
champ
she didn't bat an eye that's the world
and we left that chicken there for like
three days because this Hawk just ate
went back to the tree ate went back to
the tree it's like the Patriots always
come alright we have a Saints fan
there's been some Saints Rams news about
the hit and what happened let's do that
and then we're gonna open up to some fan
questions so think of some good ones now
funny intense insulting I don't care
it's gonna be great first thing is
Goodell comes out there and says maybe
we're gonna do some limited judgement
calls maybe we'll have some calls at the
end that's kind of like a challenge
where we look at a play that was a ref
called or a non Ref and we're able to
challenge that I'm just gonna tell you
that I think this is crazy
and I think it's an awful idea and I
don't think it's actually gonna happen
what happened to the Saints was a freak
play everyone says it was the worst
non-call ever yeah what you saw if it's
the worst non-call ever it means that
this isn't a thing that happens all the
time why would you change the entire
rulebook because of one thing that was
an absolute freak if if this was an
issue all the time let's change the
rulebook we got to figure this out this
is awful yeah right but this was one
time wherever we went it was a mistake
yeah it's a once I've never seen it have
you ever see anything like it before
let's not change the rulebook and get
all crazy I think it's a very valid
point by you I think my only change I
would like to see is make it challenge
Abul if they want it right I mean if
that was an on call I know I know but so
you could still I still think they can
make it was a penalty they might have to
talk about just going like if Bill
Belichick's on the sidelines or Sean
Payton and they see it's that egregious
yeah and they go damn no this is a big
moment I'm throwing the flag up there
let's go look at it and then the refs
see it's that egregious Larry just then
I'm for that but I don't want extra
challenge flags I don't know I don't
want to
b-26 men though I am with you and
there's no saying that even within that
it's gonna get correct right if it's
really close and it's bangbang Bill
Belichick might look at it go damn
that's past interference but Johnny
referee up in the booth he might just go
I don't know it was pretty close looks
good to me
yeah and that just doesn't mean it's
gonna solve the all the problem I just
think for me like if you listen to the
media there's always gonna be that very
popular phrase if 50 people in a bar can
see it's the case come on that's gotta
be how it is yeah it means pop me and
the boys know it's past my ferret's it
was it was awful and but I will say
sorry they had the ball in overtime they
didn't score they could have stopped the
Rams once they could have stopped the
Rams twice feels extra bad cuz he's like
oh you're like damn like really sad baby
I was expecting Saints fans to come in
here and throw things at me but because
he's like a young cool looking kid with
a cast on his arm like I like I'm just I
feel bad I feel bad kid now their coach
right Sean Payton right did a press
conference today and you've seen that
shirt with the clown Goodell shirt and
he wore that under the hoodie yeah
Sean Payton if there's one coach that
doesn't like Adele its Sean page sure
from bounty gate being suspended for a
year all that stuff you know Sean Payton
well with purposeful troll yeah he just
grabbed that off the t-shirt he's he's
shot and Peyton because he's got an edge
about him and you know he didn't like if
you if you haven't seen it yet look at
the picture and you'll see you know
anywhere that's pretty clear it's pretty
clear but he doesn't he's if this thing
doubt just enough so you could tell
that's what the shirt was right but he
was like you know if I go the whole way
and show what's Goodell that then it
becomes almost unclassy
yes so he's lot like players coaches a
lot of these coaches were athletes and
competitors in their prior life to being
a coach and they do have that edge about
him or look for that thing to motivate
him and he's pissed off and he shouldn't
be said he sat in his room for three
days and at an eight ice cream and watch
Netflix am it's like me after a break up
I hear you but what was he watching it's
gonna come out he was doing that and her
snatch not read a that's trying to do
I know he wasn't watching Pet Detective
aceman tour I know that it's a Sven
Shura pet detective okay - his favorite
movie a lot of time he said over 1 I
sent her a - when nature calls was the
greatest movie of all time
yours is what Braveheart God their God
by know about God Father takes these top
movie things and it's like I'm supposed
to be like Ebert and Roeper it's my
favorite movies yours could be Friday
and I'm like that's a great movie no
North Valley County it can't be they're
not they're not in great movies that's
funniest movie sure great movie status
ridiculousness between whiplash and Ace
Ventura - when nature calls one of those
two JK Simmons and then the chubby guy
it's good that they do the slinky on the
stairs all right we're being idiots
let's open this up oh we have two
microphones we have Nicole and Karen so
stick up your hand if you'd like to ask
a question don't be afraid it's okay I
saw a hand movement and we got a few
over here don't be scared there's no
question dumb enough for us so don't
worry we're already a lot I've opened
you up to my dumbness so I'm Michael
Polanyi what's up bro what's up man how
are you good good so my first question
actually is do you think left go has one
of those arms that will sustain time for
50 yards on the field or do you think
it's gonna go quickly like all right
results out okay so I already know
whether he got to the 50-yard mark or
not right but what do you think of my
arm I have I have a poker face you'll
never be able to tell what the results
are but your arm well if he practiced at
it he has he has a pretty natural motion
it's not bad come on not necessarily the
motion that concerns me it's just the
overall athletic ability from left oh
that's really move yeah yeah I'll last
longer the drawbridge do you think by
the hell this is the Saints fan that's
been making me feel guilty do you think
picking up Nick Foles on his option for
20 million will hurt the Eagles in the
long run hmm I think my biggest fear
though is is losing Nick Foles and not
getting anything
this notion that he's done so much for
us and that we should let him explore
free agency there's really not that many
teams that need a quarterback two of the
three are in the NFC East I don't want
to see Nick Foles on the Giants I don't
want to see Nick Foles on Washington I'm
happy to see Nick Foles in Jacksonville
or Miami get that or Miami yeah but I if
we pick up his option I think that
there's I'm not sure about this
quarterback draft class we have Kyler
Murray who's five foot nine that's gonna
scare people
we have Haskins from Ohio State who
played one year that'll scare people the
value for someone like Nick Foles we're
gonna find a team that we can trade it
for if they do extend him that extra
year but if he goes to the Giants that's
just gonna be like a stake in my heart
because it'll be Nick Foles Odell and
say Kwan and twice we've owned them is
not going to Giants no that's not
happening
Redskins I don't know you might that
neck I feel like that could happen I do
let's keep going they need to get I do
think he's right about like they gotta
get theirs this is not this is the NFL
this is not like best friend's game or
anything like that like for free no it's
they got to play business and try to get
something for him what would be myself
we're gonna go here and then we're gonna
go right behind him in the back hey so
I'm so
as a Giants fan I understand football
four years ago so I've never seen the
Giants be good right so what do you
think the Giants need to do to actually
get better and other than just like
getting rid of Eli you know yeah like at
the end of the day the OU lines still
not good right and our defense we traded
away a lot of pieces so like what does
the future hold for the Giants ya know
there's still some some holes within
that football team but they got a lot of
potential to I mean you see that they
got stars in the right position right
certainly I think offensive line is
still need a player or two there to
solidify that because I even though I do
think Eli is certainly done or very
close to being done they do need to help
him out and that in that regard and to
help sake while Barkley out I think
defensively they need they got big
people they
need like a legit edge pass rusher
Olivier Vernon's good but I don't think
he's ever gonna be a guy this is me 1214
sacks I don't think that's in his game
he's all around real good football
player and I do think that corner
another cover corner would probably be
the area I look at the most they're not
far off they really are not it would not
surprise me if they got the right pieces
in this offseason even if you know I was
the quarterback that they could manage
him a lot like I'm not saying he's up to
Tom Brady's caliber but play a style
game like we've seen New England play
here late in the season run the ball run
the ball play-action
play-action screen screen - Odell
screened us a Quan that kind of style
which will benefit him and I think the
issue can make it run with the Giants
right now is that their salary
structures insanely top-heavy they have
so much money going to just a few guys
and this is a league that's all about
depth and there's a reason Jerry Reese
got fired a lot of those draft picks two
through six or not on the team and so
they need depth and they've all that
money on solder and all that money on
Olivier they need that middle class
because as we're seeing with the
Patriots middle class you want the 53
yeah there's not a lot of teams like the
Rams that have that 11 that play the
whole time like it really is that's a
great point by left go with the middle
class I mean that's what makes New
England amazing every year when they get
injuries right we're always like man
they're injured but they're still in the
AFC Championship game because Belichick
goes after a lot of good and doesn't
always chase great with the players so
if they lose their starting middle
linebacker he's has money that has a
backup that's close to that caliber it's
not a huge drop-off where if the Rams
lost Aaron Donald right you go oh that's
this is a different team now they're not
the same or they lose one or two guys or
during a different spot and they were
fortunate to avoid that this year all
right
oh where we going now okay right here
and Rodgers impersonation spot on hey
thanks a lot man
today but I appreciate that why do you
think Todd Gurley zni is not a bigger
deal right now I do the Rams have a
chance without with Todd Gurley run ten
yards I'm not scared
I think Todd Todd Gurley is gonna be
ready to go first of all with the two
weeks off for the Super Bowl the other
thing
you gotta worry you gotta think about -
it's the Super Bowl and there's nothing
to worry about the week after right so
you can manage players and things a
little differently for this game you can
just go we're all in you got six months
to get back ready the hell with your
knee but the knee does podcast but but
then no the knee does concern me you
know it does whenever you hear about
non-contact his knee swelling up there's
constantly fluid in there it worries me
but I'm not worried about Todd Gurley
yet as the player but let's let's pump
the brakes on we're concerned about him
just because he didn't have a good NFC
Championship game CJ Anderson's NFC
Championship game wasn't special either
that was a good Rams defense let's not
forget Gurley ran 16 for 115 the week
before and Todd Gurley I still think on
the field on Sunday is the most
explosive player in the field like if
there was one guy that you go who would
you bet that has a 70 yard touchdown or
more in that game I'm taking Todd Gurley
that's what's special about him when he
sees a hole he's got enough speed to get
through it and outrun everybody the
answer actually was Gerald Everett for
the 70 yard ok what's going on man hey
giant rushing here I got a couple of
quick questions you got it
considering the head coaching turnover
that we have every year in the NFL how
much of a real advantage to veteran
coaches like Bill Belichick and Andy
Reid have over these other young coaches
and also if the Chiefs can beef up that
defense a little bit does anybody have a
chance for Patrick mahomes moving
forward and also if you guys haven't
been told this is a Falcon City yeah
yeah I would say is if I'm a cornerback
I'm calling the Chiefs and I'm saying
i'ma give you a discount I want to be on
that team
I think getting rid of Bob Sutton is a
huge step for the Chiefs just because he
played the seem deep same defense every
time and if you think about spagnolo who
today officially hire haddock so yes
what was the defense that he beat the
Patriots with in the soup right it was
about three pass rushers getting after
Tom Brady and he's got Dee Ford Chris
Jones and he's got Justin Justin Houston
so ah the Chiefs are gonna be in it for
the next decade because Patrick mahomes
is that good
I'm gonna say the thing about the
coaches to even take it a step further
somebody like Bill Belichick is so
special because he doesn't just look at
Shaun McVeigh's offense he goes who
originally created Sean McVeigh's
offense okay I can trace that back to
Shanahan and he got it from Mike
Shanahan and Mike Shanahan got it from
oh yeah right like he'll trace it to
logo that he's with Gruden and he saw
there's Gruden aspects I don't worry
about coaches they they have their
offense but they don't even understand
why their offense was created like that
we're like the Bill Belichick's of the
world they they understand everything
nothing's new to them there are no
wrinkles and then also like I'm a little
bit concerned about Sean McVeigh the
Superbowl not like I think he's going to
be great but has he ever been there in
crunch time situation with two minutes
left
wondering if he should call a timeout
like the move that Belichick did in that
Super Bowl against Seattle not calling
the timeout because he realized that
they were gonna pass the ball Seattle
was instead of running it like he saw
their sideline I don't know if Sean
McVeigh is gonna have the presence of
mind to look over and study béla check
and see which personnel he's sending in
so the advantages there are it's wild
because you've been there before and
you've done it yeah and I'll let you
take a credit no I mean she's had a lot
of good things I mean make McVeigh
McVeigh to what left go saying though I
do think he's a guy that knows the
history right like he is into it like he
grew up in it so he is gonna be a the
kind of guy that's gonna big where is
the system from where did it met all the
McVeigh impersonators the Kliff
Kingsbury is the Matloff oh yeah oh yeah
to your point would like those coaches
have an advantages certainly do I mean
there's things they just been around the
block more times than not now one area
I'll tell you that some of these coaches
have a disadvantage in though the bela
checks the Andy reads every year people
is trying to take coaches from them so
they're always having to bring up a new
group of coaches so I respect about like
Nick Saban and Alabama I feel like every
year's office of diva offensive
defensive coordinator gone and I'm so
like Dan they're still awesome it
doesn't matter that would be one asking
the Chiefs defense and the Chiefs
defense the Chiefs defense
it just needs back-end help the AFC I
mean mahomes of course the man right I
mean he's he's the only guy I wasn't
challenging but you go to the
I am see what we could have here going
into the future between him and the
Shawn Watson right Lamar Jackson Baker
Mayfield Andrew Luck's not anymore time
Sam Donald's coming up the ranks the AFC
beat Alton what and what AFC could be
one of those like it could get to that
golden era of like quarterbacks where
you go WOW and my homes will be the
class of that because my homes is like
all the greatest quarterback in the NFL
right now shoot you want to kick his ass
with me let's do it he gets really upset
because I think that my home is right
now is playing a level better than Aaron
Rodgers and I don't think on being that
react you're such a fair-weather fan
sorry
Rodgers is my number two if Aaron rod
you have Tom Brady as what all-time
three I'm scared she's not a jerk can't
believe you I know I just
there's Holmes is great all right let's
go to Brian Dawkins Pat crew will here
just curious what Chris thinks of Lamar
and his fit with the Ravens whether he's
the guy for the next 10 15 years or the
jury still out I mean get a pretty
impressive run their season into the
playoffs but guys yeah I think he's the
guy no 15 years I don't think so you
know I don't think like guys like Lamar
Jackson are gonna have the Tom Brady
type careers and until he starts to
prove that he can play that type of game
but the Lamar Jackson you know even to
Shawn Watson I worry about them at times
because they are so gifted athletically
and they can do things that Brady could
never dream of running around and doing
that but within that at the same time
they open themselves up for a lot of big
shots right I mean you saw Lamar DeSean
this year man they took some shots where
you know I'm just like please get down
get out of the way the show it was the
most psyched quarterback in the enemy
yes right and Lamar though this thing is
sneaky thing about Lamar if you go back
and really watch the year he's great and
like avoiding getting squared up where
he might you know get hit on the edge he
never gets like just act absolutely like
lambaste it so if he's gonna go this off
see ya and he's gonna throw the ball
constantly and work on it yes could we
see a monster jump in his throwing a
villain I think so I think this
experience for him in general is
he's gonna have the offseason and he's
gonna just go okay I could do this and
he's gonna go back and watch film and
he's gonna go man what an idiot I am why
didn't I go to this check there's no
jokes live controversy exactly right
they're gonna build this around him and
I think with the Ravens and the style of
play John John Harbaugh wants to play
like Smash Mouth beat you up we're gonna
play defense and then when when you
start to crowd by the line of scrimmage
Lamar is gonna bomb one over your head
or you start to condense your defense to
stop the inside run
Lamar is gonna run around the edge so
that would be my only thing he's
definitely the future he's the man I'm a
believer in Lamar but I do worry about
15 to your careers with those type of
guys Nicole with a great shuffle down
here well done all right what do we got
what's up guys Jordan so two quick
questions first one both of you guys at
stake is a Falcons fan got to ask about
Devonta Freeman yeah I know you guys are
big we're calling it the Kyle Shanahan
Offensive guys we're big Devonta Freeman
fans too okay but so two years ago had
the big year nothing since you got to be
on the field to perform I have been this
last year love Coe has an Eagles fan
all I remember for that first game of
the season is him getting blown up in
the backfield in pass blocking schemes
like thrown back whoever was deep enough
I'm in linebacker thoughts on that
second is you guys should do you guys
did the top five quarterbacks for the
draft right you guys should do a recap
of those because I know you like we
changed him around yeah as my first year
I read change this year I was appointed
myself last year I was disappointed by
the Lamar Jackson change yeah I know
yeah but you guys should do a recap of
that because that'd be cool to see yeah
yeah so cool my first thing about
Devonta Freeman is this was an offensive
line and correct me if I'm wrong that
was brought in to run Kyle Shanahan's
offense and the problem about teams
after a Shanahan leaves is that he's one
of the only guys that runs that it's
about smaller mobile offensive linemen
that can get out on the move to run that
zone scheme and then Sarkisian gets in
there and wants to run like kind of
power run sets your offensive line got
destroyed this year I mean you lost boat
you lost starting guards and backup
guards your Center got hurt it was crazy
so it's
I don't want to put it on Devante I'm
not getting emotional I just had
something in my throat but I feel like
the offensive line was a bigger issue
than Devante but I do worry about Devon
taste concussions because worse than
knees and legs it's once this starts
getting rung too much now I'm worried
about him as a human because if it keeps
and he's a physical runner but I'm
curious with you no no I mean I think
you're you're making a lot of the points
that are spot on I mean first of all the
Falcons I like that they got Dirk cutter
as the offensive coordinator I think
it's an awesome hire Dirk cutters
aggressive he's way more advanced than
finding explosive plays and then run
game and pass game as compared to a
Steve Sarkisian again I always worry
about a college guy that comes to the
NFL because you if you guys have
listened to me I always say you don't
they don't even know what they don't
know yet right they're like they're
learning on the job and they're like
wait what does this team doing how are
they blocking that and you know they're
trying to figure out things while
they're also coaching their team Devonta
Freeman - what he kind of said he runs
like he's six foot 235 but he's 5-8 206
I still think he's got tread on his tire
and I still think he can be a really
good football player but like a great
boxer I always worry about those type of
runners at that size all the car crash
hits they take all the time you get hit
out in the end of thought they can get
hit out I mean man running back in the
NFL I used to give the ball to guys and
turn around and be like oh my gosh my
neck would have broke four times on that
play like with four different engines
you really did Mike Pittman dirty I mean
Mike Pittman I got him almost killed by
Ray Lewis I felt horrible like I didn't
know what to say I mean Ray's like he's
running right here and you're like oh
crap he's right yeah I it was bad but to
your point also with the pass protection
always gonna be an issue with those type
of guys it's a big reason and I know
this and left goes heard me say this New
England believes them big linebackers
for that reason right there they go if
you want to put into your third down
Darren Sproles passed scat back whatever
and now we got Donte Hightower who's 65
to 70 running out of them good luck
trying that's that's gonna collapse the
pocket yeah
so within those type of guys you got to
be smart when you keep it in to protect
and then you got to be smart and when
you just go just send everybody out
don't even put him in that position so
here were sims's top five quarterbacks
from the trapped
Josh Allen was one Josh Rosen was two
right Baker was three right Marv four
and then my best friend in the world Sam
darn talker alive stalker alert so if
you were to refute a rearrange them now
did you yes so you would put Baker one
Baker's one
yes Baker I'm gonna guess yours yeah I
think you're gonna have Baker one right
Josh Allen to correct and I think you
might put darn 'old three I don't know
yeah you don't know this I don't know
this is I'm not even sure if I know you
know what I would probably go mmm just
from this year alone I'm gonna go Lamar
three Wow I am Lamar even the way he
played I know we're all gonna sit there
and go oh well you didn't have to throw
with that much it's not necessarily easy
to play that way when they go hey we
want you to run it and we want you to
run it and then we want you to hand it
off and then hand it off and then you
run it oh damn now make a throw on third
and ninth that's not easy to play
quarterback like that it's just not you
know it's just like a shooter when you
haven't shot the ball in a while and all
sudden it comes your way and just like
oh man this doesn't feel right I got to
get into rhythm again so I would go him
there and then Sam Donald four and then
Rosen five but three four and five is
very closed Arnold got hurt at a very
important part of the year for me to
evaluate I know he had some end of the
season success but sometimes when it's
the end of the season and the pressures
off your team and all of that it's hard
to evaluate sometimes you're playing
teams that don't have crap to do or yeah
and then sometimes you know you just
have no pressure on yourself as a team
because you're not in it so Sims there's
one thing that we really take pride in
and Sims a left ko it's not just
focusing on the stars its understanding
football and knowing yeah it makes the
money and our next guest is one of those
guys let's all welcome Kareem Jackson of
the Houston Texans to the show
how are you great
what's up kid hey you go I did it good
so Sims I would like you to formally
introduce Kareem because you have a man
crush I do have a man crush okay
just on football you're handsome too
though I don't live all minutes all
right but I mean Kareem Jackson is one
of my favorite defensive players in
football first around we always do
always talk about all Alabama corners
they never performed negative ghostrider
he's pretty awesome so is Drake Drake
Kirkpatrick and there's a lot of others
too second of all man are you a football
player I mean it's not just about years
of being kind of a lock down corner but
this year they ask you to go to safety
then there's a few injuries then you got
to go back to corner
you're the best tackling corner in
football for my money I like you throw
your body on Phillip Lindsey thank you I
appreciate it I kind of pride myself on
being physical you know I know that's
one of my best no assets you know as a
player you know so a lot of times you
see some other guys out there you know
offensive guys think they can kind of do
whatever they want you know kind of run
them over or whatever so you know for me
you know I like to be that guy that give
you a little something different out
there on the edge man you know your ass
missile don't even wait you just got you
don't break down or either you just see
it and you fly at their hips and you
take them out a lot of times when you
when you sit and wait for you break down
and that's when you miss so to me I like
to get them before they give me so I say
I pride myself on being physical out
there so Sims listen to this yeah
through 14 games he had 82 tackles 14
passes defended five tackles for loss
two interceptions two forced fumbles one
fumble return and a sack no one in 18
years had those stats in a full season
and he had it in for tame ha me man
sounds good that's pretty good that is
so so where do you think it's going to
go from here I mean because it looks
like you're about to make like the
Charles Woodson switch almost for the
Rod Woodson switch corner to safety all
right do you think it's gonna go there I
think so yeah just depends on you know
whatever team you know cuz I'm a free
agent this year just depends on whatever
team you know decides to you
bring me in on I'm opposed to anything
man I'll play from the outplay safety
I'll play corner I play the slot you
know whatever it is I go to Kansas City
but I think at this point in my career
I'll be 31 once the season starts I
think you know plenty of safety will
probably be ideal right get the most
years out of it all right you know they
kind of get ready to make that
transition right all right I have free
advice it's called left go PR what I
need you to do it's a tried and true
method Odell used it it worked and it
got him a new contract once a week you
need to put up a video cut with some
cool music of you shirt off bent like
doing some workouts cutting her hair and
it's just you just put it out every
Wednesday night and what happens is
people go man Kareem Jackson he's worth
killing already he's working right now
and then what you do is take steal the
DeAngelo Russell move and and say you
were working out at 2:00 in the morning
people be like man he never sleeps
I'm telling you man that's free advice
my I had to try that man I don't really
like to campaign you know Instagram or
are they social you know social media
sites like that I'm with you for me I
just like to let my work speak for
itself
you know and I feel like I put in you
know some good work this year so you
know if I if I gotta go to do all that
stuff with my shirt off and all that
then I didn't do what I was supposed to
do during this year all right fine work
out my shirt off again trying to get
signed by a team you are gay Jack TV are
you gonna be coming for our jobs is that
the plan out I don't want to play I
don't want to come for you guys maybe I
can join you
hey it's table big enough we can all
slide over and we can have the guest
right down there but uh that's that's
that's what I'm thinking man for me
after I'm done I definitely want to be
around the sports to you know just you
know to be around all the guys and you
know see all the fans and stuff like
that man
I love this game so you know when I'm
done I definitely want to you know do
some stuff and I commentating you know
college you know definitely you know NFL
so it's all about for me it's all about
being around it when I'm done well I
want to know about the Nick Saban
experience
okay good cool oh yeah and when you do
that because you also have Billy O'Brien
so I don't mean to cut you do my [ __ ]
like that
it's O'Brien's from Belichick savings
you know saving kind of talk about both
of them a lot of similarities men are
both rah-rah guys I know for me when I
was in college man it was it was you
know it was a culture shock for me you
know just going in coming because I came
from military school you know I was a I
went to Fort Union Military Academy Wow
and I was a high mid year guy there you
know I enrolled early at Alabama and you
know to go from obviously one of the
best guys at that school and know to get
there and being one of the first sign
ease under Saban and to get in that uh
that spring practice it just to see the
way he was you know kind of going off on
guys I'm like oh my god
what have I got myself into but I
switched from we'd love to have you you
shut the hell up and that was the thing
man because it happened so fast the way
I ended up at about my arm I ended up
meeting him at a little small airport
here in Atlanta you know who's going out
recruiting and stuff and I met him on
like a Monday I had just came back from
a recruiting visit from Maryland and you
know because I was trying to be a media
guy and you know in my mind I thought
you know I was gonna go to Maryland then
he called me that Sunday night I met him
at the airport that Monday morning Kirby
Smart jumped in the car on me and my
high school coach Herman smart we went
on Alabama looked around I was in class
that Tuesday Wow so from there to you
know getting in and just meeting him and
talking to him me you know soft voice
and stuff he finally get in that first
pregnancy like man this guy's has has
that's definitely it's wished on me it's
a 180 and I'm like man he was nothing
like this at the airport and he's extra
I've always heard he's extra heart I
mean he's a professional DB technique
guy right so he's extra hard on your
position' film room with him
individuals with him all with him you
know smart takes to uh the safeties he
with the corners all technique you know
for about 20-30 minutes
right on definitely definitely the best
time of my life though you know to go
there you know for me I wanted to go
there because I thought it'd give me the
best chance to play at the next level
you know
pro-style d fancy I just came from the
Dolphins so you know it was a great
decision for me I think so
that worked out alright man decision for
me well we I mean we talk about you a
lot because we do love to talk about
guys like you that are under the radar
superstars that we are like people that
should be in the Pro Bowl but because
like they don't the name isn't is known
they don't get the credit
popularity contest is a popularity
contest man and I kind of voice my
opinion about that this year I mean you
can say whatever you want mate it's not
gonna change it's not gonna taste like
that every year man you got guys that
deserve to be in that don't get in you
got guys that get in at in my opinion
don't deserve to be in so you know it is
what it is you know that's just how it
is but it's not gonna change because
this is my rant about the Pro Bowl
everyone says nobody cares about the
game everyone says it's a joke but then
when the careers are over and we count
out the Pro Bowls and they're going in
the Hall of Fame ago is a seven-time Pro
Bowler right and I go I thought Pro
Bowls didn't matter
alright we're incentives or your
contract yeah we're bonuses exactly and
I mean it's great to have on your resume
especially you know this time of year
you know if you're going into a free
agency but um I did in a year man if
whoever knows football they can look at
the film and you know they they can see
you know the work that you put in it so
how are you mentally preparing for a
free agency is this your first free
agency second okay you got paid once
well I didn't I didn't I actually didn't
get the free I see but this would be
yeah you know second time around yeah
how do you like how do you talk to your
agent like is it a game plan thing
because the human psyche is come on man
where the phone calls right how are you
preparing to deal with that because I
you know I've been in the been in the
league which should be my tenth year
gonna 210 so uh you know I kind of know
how it goes so you know I'm just kind of
sitting back waiting you know I feel
like you know I did what all I can do I
control what I could I could control and
that was going out and and playing the
best I could this year so for me it's
just a waiting game and I think my wife
is more on edge than me right now
because
her hair she's like you know if we had
to move like I do this I gotta do that
guys I'm I just relax I've been there
man gonna relax so you get a new spot so
I mean I'm I'm kind of looking forward
to it man you know it's a great
opportunity for me right now you know
considering the gear that I had you know
and I mean if we end up somewhere else
you know new opportunities that's how I
look at it so I'm actually excited about
it well you ain't clowny free agent well
that's where I want to go next like I
mean you talk about the popularity
contest you've got a lot of those guys
on the Houston Texans like you know I I
don't even know where to start I really
want you just to go through like the
checklist of some of the super freaks on
your team like tell me about your day
beyond tell me your first thoughts about
the Shaun Watson JJ Watt did I miss
anybody else I think those are the three
and DeAndre Hopkins like just kind of
give me a I start with the two guys that
make my job easier right now because
obviously JJ man you see the type of guy
he is and somebody just asked me you
know was this year more about you know
uh you know him just you know just
wanting to go out and you know it's kind
of get back on track and you know and
and I guess he just wanted to prove to
himself that you know he could still go
out and you know play the high level and
also prove other everybody wrong you
know uh cuz yeah some people probably
saying that he was done you know but um
you seen him work on a day-to-day basis
man he worked like no other you know
it's two guys in this league that I I
see that I've seen work on a consistent
basis and I'm like no I'm not doing that
is Eric Berry and JJ Eric Berry worked
like I've never seen before and JJ does
the same and and it shows and those guys
played but what is what is crazy because
as someone who goes to the gym once
every two weeks we'll put it at I think
that's the over yeah that might be too
many I always a suit we assume that you
guys are you ain't with me in the gym
like I always assume that's going on all
right
what about their workouts were that much
crazier that it caught your attention
well I turned with Arab area in South
Florida
I trained there ever since I came out
and we'll do a full two hour workout
non-stop training
like and after we finish and I look
around and everybody we all just like
blow tire like there's nothing we can't
do anything else he'll take a ten minute
break into another hour and a half of
just like little footwork stuff like you
know speed that I'm like man I'm going
home man I see y'all tomorrow ain't
doing that say cuz I don't I don't have
anything lo yeah but I mean what about
JJ or cloudy oh yeah yeah
Kanye's one of those guys he's one of
those those rare guys this and your
career you probably played with one or
two guys in your head you probably say
they can get out of the bed and put
their stuff on and go out there and and
do whatever they want to do anybody
he's one of those out yes one of those
guys found he's one of those guys one of
those guys he just come in and he's just
God takes his shirt off and it and he
looked like a DB like ABS yeah rocked up
and you like man and you look at him
he's like come on Connor we're gonna go
you know run some extra sprints do that
he's like oh yeah we can do it and then
just kind of get out there and he outrun
all the DBS and all that stuff just a
just a physical freak I mean I'm amazed
by his power cuz like it's just like
he's not like you know I know he's
muscular the wiry but he knows right
he's not like jjv right he's like I said
you kind of take his shirt off he needs
just chills what like a DB but when I
say just freakish athlete scary right
he's one of those guys and get out of
the bed and just go play and he'll get
you two three sacks yeah it's a couple
guys you know like I said you play with
you in Korean yeah he can do anything
you want fresh out of the bit exactly so
did you know that you're an elite club
of 13 guys in the NFL that not many
people are in it's a club that we love
here it's called the Blake bortles pick
six seven thirteen times everybody
Kareem Jackson is one of those guys
right all right I'm being I'm being kind
of an ass
wait no we gotta hear about DeSean and
Hopkins how much how about Blake bortles
oh my gosh stop all right fine I gotta
hear about the show talking about portal
yeah
deshaun maze is just a special talent
man I think he's gonna be you know the
best best quarterback in this game you
know and in a couple years you know I
mean we all see the numbers he put up
you know the thing that makes him so
good man I think is its approach to you
know you know getting better on a
day-to-day basis you know it carries
itself like a ten year vet you know and
one of the things that makes them you
know so hard to prepare for he can
extend plays you know you got a guy that
can extend plays man and make those off
skills who plays man it's tough to play
against those guys because you know if
that first reads not open you know he's
gonna run around until you find somebody
or he could run for 10 to 15 yards and
that's tough you know you got him third
and long and you know he scrambled for
15 20 yards and I extended drive man
that's tough but um he's definitely you
know a leak guy I mean like I said man
every day you know he's the leader
carries himself like a ten year Batman
so on I wish fuller was healthy because
that offense when it's fuller and
Hopkins and the high-low it was like
unstoppable so 37 points a game seeing
those guys every day in practice man it
definitely definitely makes you a lot
better yeah the best receiver in the
game I think so yeah it's time to go to
the land I think so man just you know
what he does on a consistent basis you
know um I think all our staff does a
great job of kind of moving in Marana
put him in different spots but um I mean
we're going out with him still getting a
double man he's still open yeah crazy
because his his his hands is that and
traffic guys draped all over him and you
know he's making one-handed catches like
he's catching against his helmet or
right and this is all kind of crazy
stuff man on every year he has three or
four insane catches that he like it is
there's no way how about the Dallas game
and over time this year that play like
40 yards to set up the game one and he
has sneaky speed he has sneaky speed but
um I mean I think he I think he's the
best in the game I think so thinks Tyree
kills the best in the game yeah yeah I
mean I do I think he's the most
dangerous in the game right now he can't
he can't catch any of those type of
place but before you go this is it like
the receiver that you've gone against
that just you're just always like wow
like gosh damn that guy's good not
Hopkins you know somebody else on
another team it's a couple guys in the
game and obviously Julio in Atlanta so I
played in school with him so I had the
pleasure of seeing him you know every
day in practice but you know obviously
Julio man with the numbers he put up you
know year in the year out on Tyree Hill
yeah it's for me man it's those guys
with that speed man and in that
quickness
yeah you know um they back you off to
where you always have to worry about
yeah cuz and then not only that once
they catch it you got to get them down
right you got to get them down like you
know they run out to catch guys no Dale
you know those guys man that can run
away from me once they catch it man
that's that's tough man so we played
against old Oh this year and you know a
lot of his lot of his yards came on you
know yeah ours
all right so how excited were you guys
to play the Jaguars the last few years I
be serious
he's not good
like I'm saying this is not him it's not
him I am saying this it's okay but like
let's let's be real though always
excited - always excited man I think I
got him twice to the crib - twice to the
13 yeah got him twice like like with his
Jacksonville like are you guys in the
locker room like the week of the game
going I want to pick six no I want to
fix yeah I got him twice man I think
another one of my teammates got him too
but um I mean but for me man we Pike
that's all I love thinking when we play
them and especially like I said I got
him twice you know so I mean if you
already enjoy it and then you're right
the safety corner switch your careers
gonna go on for like ten more you keep
it going man
don't forget about lemonade er that
might work it might increase a few
dollars I'm just telling you definitely
all right so here's what's going on if
you're listening to the podcast Jarvis
Landry is gonna be up next if you're
here at Dan Tana's it's gonna be at 7:15
alright hold on alright so we are back
with a wide receiver that has some cash
in his pockets of talent with his hands
and some swagger that drips through his
whole day of body Jarvis Landry I might
be the better unless you have a guy it's
it's not often that NFL players have a
catchphrase say it bless bless hard
knocks
from the speech to the bless of all of
that could you feel the fame like it was
it was it weird for that to happen as it
was going on now I mean I didn't think I
didn't think you were you know touch as
many people as it did and you know I
went out to practice pretty much
probably the next day and everybody
signs headbands shirts and you've been
saying this for a long time no I just
came up on the spot one time that one
time
oh please from Ochocinco so you like
bless him I love bless okay good good I
wasn't sure if that your self bestowed
upon you now I love it
you got blessed you got a baby boy
coming man I do congratulations
hey hey that's awesome but we're gonna
start with a little bit of Twitter beef
oh I think we should start there bless
of blessing left I wanna I want to air
out all the real so one thing that
stinks about working at bleach report we
want to be the players podcast but
people want to know who his top five
wide receiver trios are and so what
happens is we're gonna upset some people
you made the comment that you Corey
Coleman Josh Gordon were the number one
waters here truly NFL so Sims put out
his top five Browns weren't on it and
then you hit crying emoji crying emoji
crying emoji Sims doesn't understand
emojis that well and he was like is he
laughing at me it really upset him
so we're just I want to get that other
way I don't want to ever lie to you I
mean if the fact that you know they both
get traded within the next couple of
weeks so maybe you were right arguing at
the time like the potential was there to
be the top tier so like I know you're
not listening to us on a daily basis but
of course when we saw your crying emoji
like we had fun with it almost I did but
at the same time yeah my point was hey
we know you're the man but we hadn't
seen Josh in a while Corey had not
really lived up to anything to that
point so I didn't have you my top five
but it does it hurts my heart when
people like you commenter because i
don't want you not to like me I like you
so much I mean I saw the potential I saw
the potential I know I don't well how
about potential like let's just go right
there like your team in Cleveland you
they signed you to change the culture
there because your attitude your work
ethic everything like that but how about
just what you brought to the table and
now the Baker effect you know just
talking about the team in general and
and what he's like playing with um
I mean well
honestly when I first got there it was
it was just it wasn't that it was a bad
culture it was just a young football
team you know a young football team and
trying to find our identity a lot of
different coaching changes and things
like that you know I think the whole
thing with me was it's about mindset you
know my game starts with a mindset you
know when I starts in practice and just
kind of this when everybody caught wind
of the speech you know just kind of what
I was given to the room you know the
mindset behind myself but I think behind
all winners all true competitors you
know they feel that way you know nothing
could hold him back from trying to be
great you know so that kind of went for
a while and then obviously Baker gets
his opportunity to step in and you know
go do that feel oh my goodness you know
like when in pre-season your best
quarterback was Ryan Tannehill and now
you got Baker Mayfield like holy you
don't have to say anything okay
I mean obviously you know now and
obviously you knew in the regular season
but like when the preseason was going
did you think like did you think he was
gonna be sure well obviously you know
the talent you saw right away ya know
you know but going into the season there
was already a plan in place you know the
tie rods gonna be the starter and he's
gonna play this season you know and then
the Jets game happened and tie rakhie
down to nothing bring it back 17 and
it's like at that point it's like you
can't ever put him on the bench again
like there was a difference
so what was the energy like after that
game like for the team going forward
like were you that Monday did you go
into the facility and everyone's like
holy crap like it was it palpable
well instantly after the game was over
the the streets looked like they won the
NBA Finals of you want a Super Bowl or
something you know I think that was a
Thursday night game you know I don't
think people went back to work again
till Monday they open coolers you know
the the dilly dilly coolers and yeah
you know so but it was good man the
energy everything I think you know from
that point on we kind of started kind of
trying to understand what winning was
again we had a young football team yeah
so we're still growing in some areas and
you know we lost probably the next two
games before we kind of went on a
winning streak after the coaching chop
okay so that's where we got to go
Thanks right if you want to tell us the
drama now actually the drama guys I mean
I mean just it's the timeline I mean
okay so we got the Baker effect yeah
then you know you lost a few games and
then there was the hew effect right and
I'm not trying to start [ __ ] but I guess
I am kind of - is like what about Hugh I
mean obviously Baker had some issues
there but what was it about the change
that kind of like re-energized the team
for lack of a better phrase well we were
young again you know we were young and
we were trying to figure out our
identity and and and who we were and I
think there were a lot of things growing
up upstairs that we couldn't control you
know how to have our hand in and you
know Dee and Jimmy they and mr. Dorsey
they straighten it out and and got it
situated but I think the biggest thing
for us I think the turnaround came when
it wasn't a special players meeting or
anything like that it was just guys in
the locker room just talking amongst
each other and saying like this is our
team like we're gonna go as far as we
want to go we have to talent we can make
the plays we could play with anybody
let's do it and then Freddie kitchen yes
that's right like what was that what was
the thing that he maybe did in the
offense like schematically that you were
just like oh it was awesome it look like
completely different I mean again and
when you first call plays when you first
start calling players especially in
Freddie kitchen situation who did an
amazing job you know and I think the
beauty about the whole thing was he
didn't have any tendencies so when we
every time we took the field you didn't
know what you were gonna get we started
pulling out trick plays and we have you
running around on the end around that we
have you on the same play but then
throwing the deep ball yeah which is
that's what great Aussies do I find one
concept and build things off exactly so
then I mean what do you think about
Freddie what do we need to know that you
know that we don't I mean besides you
know besides him calling great ass plays
on on game day yeah
I mean there's not much just but hehe
just the story of Freddie kitchens is
the guy that never got a chance and I
think about the Browns and I go what a
perfect guy to lead them and then when I
add in the fact that it was so funny to
watch the old and I'm gonna say it white
ass media get upset with Baker for
having an attitude and say it no no no
he he like left us and all that
I think Cleveland needed that yeah I
think they need a guy like Baker that's
not afraid of anybody that's gonna take
it and it feels like there's a new
identity do you believe there is one I
absolutely do believe it and I'm
everybody could see it I'm sure
everybody sees everybody I ran into you
know we're not happy with the season
that we had obviously cuz you'll be
playing this game but everybody does
I've ran into has you know they see the
potential in us and obviously we see it
too so we're excited but we know we got
work to do what did you learn from a
team in the Ravens game because that was
it was a pride game for you it was sort
of like a play-in game for them what did
you learn from a game that really had a
lot of importance well we team fully
full of heart I mean we full of heart no
quick I mean they're still plays in that
game net I mean I dropped the but pass
that hit me off the damn face man it's
like you know like that was wide open
and I was oh I'm still fighting that
demon but I'm you know and to lose the
way we did but we competed and we never
gave up where they were down by 14 at
one point you know we never gave up and
I think that that's kind of the heart
and soul of our team the true identity
of us I got one more for you for a
longest time the AFC North it was like
the Steelers at the top and the Browns
at the bottom do you believe that North
is up for grabs
absolutely and do you believe that
you're gonna take it absolutely oh did
you see the look but what like what a
great feeling yeah it's and is it more
than hope it's like confidence it feels
like absolute lease
I mean I think for us again holding
might fall down
Oh first time we felt that but it's a it
sounds like confidence about the north
yeah it is and you know again it's part
of the mindset and it's a part of you
know us when we take the feel this is
hope it's not hoping to win is expecting
to win you know and I think that that's
that's what how we come an issue love it
I want to take it back earlier right
because I'm always amazed by this first
of all I mean you and Odell Beckham jr.
are on the same damn team but forget
just you two Jeremih he'll take just
take the nay like the names you had on
that team
I'm always like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with LSU why can't you guys get it
together sorry sorry to swear in front
of you young man but like just speak
about that team did you realize all of
you were such special players and
defensa yes everything peons is on the
yeah it's a tough I still don't have I
still don't have an answer after all
these years you know I get asked all the
time how did we ever lose the game you
know but you know Bama the tough team to
beat and a lot of times you got to beat
them they win the West and you know you
know we didn't get that accomplished
only about once and most of my freshman
year we went to the national
championship and then we had to play
them again oh yeah you know and it's
always tough to be the next segment team
twice who is the official owner of the
nickname juice because I feel like
there's a lot of guys in the league that
call themselves juice and like my name
was given to me no I didn't I think was
so juice to you Josh the worst ik at LSU
actually huh he's a six year scene whoa
so like the juice thing how you're
saying a lot of people have it yeah it's
usually given to the guy who brings
energy to the locker room of the field
every day even when you're playing north
east south Louisiana state he's still
going this Alabama when other people are
called juice Le'Veon is calls himself
juice he's got juice on his team yeah
he's the juice that
gotcha maybe you're like juice with pulp
and he's like juice from constant so
Sims and I are friends and I would say
our dynamic is on the goofball and he's
sort of like the guy that keeps it
straight he goes to bed on time
what is the phret dynamic with Odell
probably I'm I'm this guy your head you
have it like the straight narrow then
Odell's like dancing all the time yeah
absolutely you see it all the time it's
not just who he is yeah it's how it's
who he's always been to since high
school he didn't change up none of that
he's always been the same person as
someone that's his friend and he's so
discussed all the time and there's so
many people a TV that have never met him
that want to tell people what he's like
what is the most frustrating thing that
you hear about him that you wish you
could like tell the truth um that he's
selfish or that he's a diva for a cylon
antics or whatever it is like he's the
most unselfish guy that I've ever played
with that I've ever known one of the
most selfish guys that unselfish guys
that I've ever known and you know just
understanding him and knowing him and
what he's been through in his story
you know man you gotta be in a room with
them you know you got to talk to him
yeah I really understand him to really
know who he is and yeah how much passion
he really has behind this game that he
loves to play more than anything else
that he does in in his life it's
football this game you know I
he got my dad and my brother tickets to
an Eagles Giants game and Odell's
parents were sitting right next to them
and my dad came home he goes I
understand O'Dell from hearing his
parents yell the entire game yeah a
passion it's all passion non-stop yeah
yeah yeah that this this is like why I
love football though just so you know I
just gonna give you like peel back the
curtain so we're in the back of the
greenroom
all right and he comes in and you know
what he's talking about
like this is why he's Jarvis Landry he's
talking to Kareem Jackson about what
he's doing working out this offseason
what are you doing who you training with
what's the group like how big of a group
do you like to train with like that's
the crap I like to hear that's why I
like guys like you and Kareem Jackson I
mean do you wake up I know that you just
season just ended your
still in rest mode but do you wake I
mean what's the thing that goes through
your head when you wake up in the
morning well I mean for me I mean it's a
lifestyle obviously training and working
out is the lifestyle but I think
personally on a on a professional level
I want to be the best you know and I
approach I approach training that way I
approach you know working out with the
best you know I want to be around guys
that are considered elite or considered
the best you know so I know what the
standard is and what a bar is you know
and try to raise it you know for myself
and for other guys right so say quad
went on TV today and said he believes
he's Rookie of the Year you're you play
with the other Rookie of the Year
candidate do you agree with sake one or
should this be Baker's award at the top
one it should be because award but but
you know um I think both of them you
don't have hell over years you know
they're both ballers they both ballers
they I was thinking given to both of
them you know I know they can I've seen
it before well have they can they should
but if they had to do what you would
take Baker like what would be your
argument for Baker well I mean you know
the first game he played in he was
against the eight ball you know I mean
Fort down 14 nothing at halftime you
know he comes in and you know he throws
his first touchdown pass he you know
leads us through a victory the first
victory in what three years oh you feel
like you know and you know from there I
mean obviously the both guys have broke
broken records and and things like that
but you know as a quarterback you know
it's it's always the guy that touches
the ball first and you know gets the
most recognition but again I will say
that you know sacrum Buckley has had a
year that I'm excited to see what he
gonna do next year I think what's
exciting to me about you and Baker is
you're a kind of guy that might not blow
people off the line but if the ball is
near you it's coming down and Baker's
not afraid to throw that ball right and
not every NFL quarterback is willing to
throw that ball and that's why the
amount of times he throws it past the
dudes ear hole and you're like that that
connection is what excites me for you
guys and it's it's what he's done he's
always done it you know and he's a gamer
I caught his first pass you know and
I've caught passes way
I don't even know how I caught you know
but he put it in positions where you
know only I could I could I can make the
play and he's trusted me what's he like
in the huddle funny very funny
he's very funny just to keep everybody
yeah yeah are like talking to fans you
know that that's that's you know booing
him I something like that he's talking
[ __ ] back to him you know like just just
things like that you know he's really
wearing you know he understands we are I
always like to ask anybody this just for
you receiver you're the top of the NFL
is one of the best receivers in the game
who were the corners that come to your
mind just right off the bat when you go
man I that guy right there I know it's
gonna be a tough day's work
you know who's that one or two guys that
always bothers you or just annoys you
well I mean I our division has a couple
of good ones you know brand new car
Jimmy Smith yeah yeah I mean who teams
for you to King King from San Diego just
in case but so you know what's
interesting is that you're saying some
these guys those are like the some
physical guys other than maybe Joe
Hayden so does the physical guy annoy
you more than maybe the quicker smaller
guy no it's just it's just a smart it's
just a smarter players I think some of
those guys are smart and then you know
obviously with the Ravens they play in a
great system you know what about doing
the things that he's doing back there
confusing the quarterback you know
confuse him
you know the receivers as well because a
lot of times we get our reads off of the
safety he's at the line
you know and then Jimmy Jimmy Smith and
Bernie carbo being longer guys yes you
know they're being longer guy so you
know when I get them down to the slot
then that's more my world you know
especially against big taller taller
guys yeah we're right yeah you know but
all those guys are pretty good matchups
yeah what's it like to play in the same
city as LeBron I don't play in LA
[ __ ] damn I was alive is IG and I've
seen him tap up LeBron and I'm thinking
LeBron is the King and LeBron is out
like his omnipresent he's in Cleveland
he's in LA wherever he is he takes over
the world like play here in the same
city is Jordan I am getting red right
now Jarvis we appreciate you
congratulations on the baby boy and
we're so excited for you have a great
year we're excited for you have a baby
boy at quarterback and finally got one
by the way you play at the Jets this
season so you could rub it in out of
cases face I said it you did say it
don't worry about for Jarvis forcing
feet that'll be for fence Rick good
evening I am the lef koe man we will
hollow out